hallo viktor hallo christoph ich hätte
drei fragen an victor und zwar die erste
wäre wie kam es zu dem kanal nahe my
belly schon wem oder was hast du dich da
inspirieren lassen so ja hallo ich frage
mal eins wie kam ich auf lade ich hatte
damals einen anderen kanal der hieß nur
bla li und ich war komplett neu anfangen
und weil bleiben ihnen war schon
vergeben war musste ich mich einladen
nennen quasi in anspielung auf die apple
produkte hier ipad und ipod und alles
mögliche meine zweite frage wäre was
willst du von dieser ganzen kolonie 2012
sache juni 2012 betrachte ich ein
bisschen kritisch kann das so eine sache
ist so viele denken viele denken er
jetzt mit einem klick da rede ich die
welt mit das ist nicht unbedingt so
steckt immer was da hinter uns was
dahinter steckt das muss man selber
rausfinden und meine dritte frage ist
was für tipps würdest du youtube auf den
weg geben wenn sie
auf youtube was schaffen wollen tipps
für youtube was kann man besser machen
oder was kann man machen um erfolgreich
zu werden man sollte auf jeden fall spaß
dran haben man sollte wirklich
leidenschaft der versuchen zu
integrieren und man sollte versuchen
wirklich man selbst zu bleiben also
nicht zu verstellen und einfach sein
eigenes ding durchziehen und das machen
wonach man am meisten spaß hat also wenn
man zum beispiel musik macht dann sollte
man musik machen wir uns beispiel kommen
die machen will dann machen einfach
kommen die also einfach das worauf er
bock hast